[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory today
we're going to be discussing the five
most powerful witches and wizards the
key from Slytherin house at Hogwarts now
of the four houses at Hogwarts
we know Slytherin as the house that gets
a bit of a bad rap there's not a single
witch or wizard it went bad it wasn't in
Suffern Hagrid famously remarks but in
reality becoming bad or evil is not
actually a defining characteristic of a
southern student and Hagrid remark is
actually quite inaccurate their poor
reputation with the other houses aside
southern house has produced some of the
greatest and most powerful Wizards the
world has ever seen
Salazar Slytherin one of the four
founders of Hogwarts valued students who
were clever resourceful and determined
but also those who in Dumbledore's words
had a certain disregard for the rules
these were all characteristics that
matched the founders own values
interestingly enough Dumbledore would
also later note that these were actually
all characteristics of Harry Potter
however as we know he was placed in
Gryffindor over Slytherin after some
deliberation by the salting yet
sovereigns have a lot going for them and
are often strong leaders as we have seen
in Tom Riddle and well Salazar Slytherin
himself they are also highly ambitious
cunning and achievement oriented unlike
the other founders Salazar Slytherin a
tendency to favor pureblood students
over muggle-borns and half-bloods for
his house and this is actually something
that the sorting hat takes into account
when sorting students Ron is pretty open
about his opinion of Salazar 13 I always
knew Salazar Slytherin was a twisted old
loony but I never knew he started all
this pure blood stuff I wouldn't be in
his house if you paid me honestly the
Sorting Hat had tried to put me in
Slytherin I'd have got the Train
straight back home it's not uncommon for
Slytherin students to form groups which
leaves the opening for someone to assume
the role of group leader
see this with Malfoy and his gang as
well as Tom Riddle who formed his own
gang while at school the same gang that
were gone to become the forerunners to
what would become the Death Eaters so
they're powerful but who are the five
most powerful to have ever lived let's
jump into it number five Bellatrix
Lestrange Bellatrix Lestrange born
Bellatrix black of the house of black
was an english pureblood witch who would
have attended hogwarts around 1962
Bellatrix was the eldest of her siblings
and is the older sister of andromeda
Tonks and necessar Malfoy it should come
as no surprise that Bellatrix was sorted
into Slytherin house during her time at
the school shortly after leaving she
became a Death Eater and became known by
many as one of Voldemort's most loyal
and dangerous followers she was widely
considered to be one of the most feared
witches in the visiting world her
fear-inspiring name and bloodthirsty
reputation were well deserved and she
was known to have murdered and tortured
numerous witches and wizards including
neville longbottom parents her magical
abilities were more than impressive as
she was trained in the dark arts by Lord
Voldemort himself she displayed a
particular proficiency and affinity for
the Cruciatus curse and she claimed to
have a knowledge of dark spells that was
hard to comprehend this claim was backed
by Voldemort himself Bellatrix was also
a known proponent of the killing curse
but she often didn't use it until she
had sufficiently tortured her victim she
has a track record of taking on numerous
auras and order of the Phoenix members
and she was even known to have deflected
a spell from Albus Dumbledore himself
making her the only Death Eater to
escape from him this is just another
example of her formidable magical
abilities that reinforces her position
on this list number 4 Severus Snape
Severus Snape was born in 1962 a muggle
father and witch mother Snape began
attending Hogwarts in 1971 along with
Harry's mother Lily Evans despite not
being a pureblood Snape was sorted into
Slytherin while Lily was sorted into
Gryffindor this was very hard on Snape
as he was in love with Lily
from a very young age while still very
young Snape began to practice the dark
arts fueled by the rage stemming from
incessant bullying at the hands of James
Potter series black and the Marauders
Snape ended up joining the Death Eaters
along with other sovereigns from his
year and sleep acted as a double agent
during the Wizarding war amazingly for
the duration of the visiting war he was
able to stop Voldemort from reading his
mind which is a testament to his power
as an Aquaman's it was clear that Snape
was very talented from a very young age
and while learning his primary course
material at Hogwarts he would scribble
in his notebook and invent curses charms
and potions under the alias the
half-blood Prince
Snape would scribble these into his
potions textbook which contained many
powerful spells some of these spells
include lava corpus the muffler auto
charm
vulnera sanentur and Sectumsempra which
if cast on an enemy is like slashing
them all over their body with an
invisible sword if you ever had any
doubt in your mind at all guarding
Snape's power it's worth mentioning that
he was even recognized to be a powerful
wizard by Lord Voldemort himself Snape
was only 38 years old when he died
but in the time that he was alive he
showed so much promise and so much
expertise in so many different areas I
think could have Snape would to have
survived the Wizarding war he could have
been one of the most powerful wizards
ever and I truly believe that he could
have contended power wise with the likes
of Dumbledore and Voldemort number three
Salazar Slytherin Salazar Slytherin you
might have heard the surname was one of
the four founders of Hogwarts alongside
Rowena Ravenclaw Helga Hufflepuff and
Godric Gryffindor it has been expressed
that the power of the Hogwarts founders
is thought to be uncompelled to most
modern-day witches and wizards and sours
ask for the rent is no exception
he was a pureblood wizard that was born
sometime before 976 a.d given that
Hogwarts was founded around 990 ad my
best guess that he would have been born
sometime between
932 960 AD however given that he was
immensely powerful he may have been
around for much much longer than that
Slytherin did not like muggle-born
students and was a strong proponent of
having only pureblood students at
Hogwarts this philosophy was ultimately
passed on to other slytherins his
response to muggle-born students
attending the school was to build the
chamber of secrets which concealed a
basilisk that was intended to purge the
school of these students
he felt that muggle-borns were unworthy
of studying magic though we don't know
too much about him we do know that he
was extremely powerful in casting dark
charms and spells and he was notably
skilled at legitimacy wand making
baseless breeding and charms having
helped to create the sorting hat number
2 Merlin Merlin isn't alluded to much in
the Harry Potter universe but we do know
a few things about him and he is
referenced in a few places
he is most often mentioned when the
popular phrase Merlin's beard is used
and we know that he is the founder of
the order of Merlin which is both an
award was stowed upon witches and
wizards who have achieved great deeds as
well as a group advocating rules which
prevented spells from being used on
muggles so even though he was a
Slytherin he really wasn't such a bad
guy this just goes to show that not all
Lutheran's are evil Merlin's portrait
can be found on the wall in Hogwarts as
well as on a chocolate frog cart Merlin
is said to have been one of the most
powerful wizards that ever lived and his
name alone is known by every witch and
wizard Merlin was alive during the
medieval era and was a member of King
Arthur's Court Hogwarts was founded in
1990 ad and there are a few different
theories floating around in regards to
the year that Merlin attended the school
some sources indicate that Merlin was
born in 982 ad which would make him one
of the very first students at Hogwarts
this would also mean that Merlin was
taught directly under founder Salazar
Slytherin's tutelage however this is all
speculation and other sources state that
he was a student
between the 11th and 15th century I'm
inclined to lean towards the former
theory because I think that some of
Merlin's power could be attributed to
him having a teacher as powerful as
Salazar Slytherin Merlin was sorted into
Slytherin house during his time at
Hogwarts and was known to be a master of
charms his skill in using charms and
enchantments was so adept that he is
commonly referred to as the Prince of
enchanters but not only was Merlin
powerful he was also a good guy and as I
mentioned earlier believed in muggle
rites and wanted harmony between muggles
and a magical world and finally number
one Voldemort
Voldemort is undoubtedly one of the most
powerful if not the most powerful Dark
Wizard in the entire Harry Potter
universe born Tom Marvolo riddle in 1926
Voldemort began attending Hogwarts in
1938 and was sorted into none other than
southern house Dumbledore and Voldemort
are thought to possess fairly equal
power with the obvious exception of one
practicing magic for good and another
practising it for evil one of his
earliest acts of evil was when he opened
Salazar's lorenz
Chamber of Secrets while attending the
school in order to cleanse the school of
muggle-borns even at a young age
Voldemort proved himself to be a magical
prodigy as he was able to utilize and
control magic without the use of a wand
he had the power to move objects with
his mind to communicate with and control
animals and even inflict harm on those
who opposed or annoyed him he even left
Dumbledore astonished vol what performed
feats of magic thought impossible and
his magical accomplishments eclipsed and
dwarfed those of any Dark Wizard before
him with the exception of perhaps
Grindelwald Volta Mort began
experimenting with the dark arts at a
very young age and even began creating
his first Horcrux at the age of 16
eventually splitting his own soul into a
total of 8 fragments Voldemort was also
a Parseltongue meaning he could speak to
snakes which is often an indicator the
you are descendant of Salazar Slytherin
himself volume was also exceptionally
skilled at a clemency and
legitimacy meaning that he was an expert
at penetrating the mind of others while
being able to keep others out of his
some examples of his long list of
abilities include flying creating
Horcruxes creating spells notably
laws mods which summons the dark mark
controlling in faerie possessing living
creatures and Transfiguration and that's
it for this list honorable mentions
include Horace Slughorn who didn't quite
cut it and Lucius Malfoy who pulled the
flag that he gets is actually quite a
gifted wizard I think that depending on
the sort of skills that you value you
could rearrange some of the spots on
this list but I'm fairly happy with this
outcome I talked about rearranging the
top three but I think there's just so
much evidence to reinforce Lord
Voldemort as most powerful Dark Wizard
and southern graduate to have ever lived
a lot of people claim that Merlin is the
greatest wizard to have ever lived
period but we just don't have enough
information on him so I can't say that I
can confidently put him in the top
position on this list let me know what
you guys think down in the comment
section below
remember Slytherin graduates only until
next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]